sie nennt sich tencent für ihre musik
braucht sie nur ein keyboard und ihre
stimme
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ihr glück hier in deutschland zu sein
kann die australische singer songwriter
win kaum fassen das ist wirklich das
verrückteste das mir je passiert ist ich
glaube es nicht aber ich bin genauso wie
ich vor einem jahr war ich trage
übergröße bin kein stylisches disney
kind vor einem jahr spielte sie noch auf
den straßen melbourne und jetzt
welttournee mit großen musiklabel kids
are coming wurde in einem monat zwei
millionen mal angesehen alles drin was
die freude future generation bewegt die
neue kita team berg nein dieser song
hast viel mehr als protest es geht um
klimawandel umweltzerstörung ausgrenzung
von menschen und darum dass wir alle
entschlüsse fassen müssen
erst wenn wir das tun dann ändert sich
wirklich was trifft eine entscheidung
jetzt klare worte von einer 19-jährigen
dass ausgerechnet australien jetzt
erwägt die klimaschutz proteste zu
verbieten
verstört sie
das ist unfassbar jahr aber bei den
jüngsten protesten in melbourne haben
sie meinen song kids are coming gesungen
das hat mich schwer beeindruckt dass ich
mit meinem song offenbar die leute
ermutigen mit mir zu gehen und die
meinung zu sagen
die saison der hier alle mitreißt heißt
dance monkey
[Musik]
[Applaus]
auf spotify 331 millionen mal gespielt
von 1000 werden wir noch mehr hören
[Musik]